bonjour à tous bienvenue sur l'antenne
de lcp public sénat on va refaire l'actu
politique et parlementaire de la semaine
c'est l'heure de parlement hebdo avec
michaël szames fo jean pierre bonjour
michael cette semaine a été marquée par
le départ de christiane taubira du
gouvernement celle qui saura rester près
de quatre ans garde des sceaux a quitté
le gouvernement en raison d'un désaccord
politique majeure at-elle dit jean
jacques urvoas la remplace même jour de
ce départ manuel valls étaient devant la
commission des lois pour présenter la
nouvelle formule retenue sur la
déchéance de nationalité
la référence aux binationaux a disparu
du texte mais la polémique elle continue
et puis remarquer cette semaine de
dialogue de sourds dans l'hémicycle sur
le projet notre dame des landes cécile
duflot a interpellé le gouvernement sur
ce dossier sensible réponse cinglante du
premier ministre on verra tout à l'heure
et pour commenter toute cette actualité
christophe caresche et notre invité
bonjour bonjour vous êtes député du
parti socialiste député de paris vous
faites partie de ceux que l'on appelle
le pôle des réformateurs les
réformateurs
ce sont ceux qui sont sur la ligne de
manuel valls on est bien d'accord avec
cela oui vous allez votre mémoire vous
au rex unités et vous expliquer dans un
instant va commencer que c'est par la
suite dé nos sujets
soixante et une proposition lundi pour
rappeler les principes fondamentaux du
code du travail c'est le rapport pain
d'inter l'ancien garde des sceaux de
françois mitterrand a remis son travail
à manuel valls le rapport servira de
base au projet de loi présenté par
myriam el khomri stéphanie des pierres
c'est l'acteur de la réforme du code du
travail
robert badinter a remis son rapport à
manuel valls rédigé par un comité de
neuf juriste le texte réaffirme
clairement la place du cdi
pas question non plus de remettre en
cause le smic sur les heures
supplémentaires le rapport badinter ne
prend pas vraiment position mais il
martèle l'idée que tout salarié qui
travaille plus de 35 heures a droit à
une compensation
le premier ministre lui aussi écarte
toute remise en cause des 35 heures il y
a une durée légale normale du temps de
travail
elle est aujourd'hui fixée à 35 heures
demain elle peut être modifiée enfin
c'est pas le sens de ce que nous
préparons le gouvernement veut
simplifier le code du travail le rendre
plus lisible et plus souple mais pour la
droite il faut accélérer les réformes
je crains que ce ne soit namibie à une
forme d'immobilisme
monsieur macron a fait des déclarations
nous attendons aujourd'hui qu'elle se
traduise en actes les 35 heures
aujourd'hui ils sont une source de
blocage or nageurs il faut lever cette
source de blocage si vous ne touchez pas
réellement dans l'année 2016 au temps de
travail si vous ne touchez pas à ce que
le contrat unique
je vois pas bien en quoi ça peut
permettre la création de l'emploi
les 61 principes énoncés par le rapport
badinter deviendront le préambule du
nouveau code du travail
ils guideront évidemment le projet de
loi de réforme du code du travail
mejia mike comrie le présentera le 9
mars prochain en conseil des ministres
alors ce rapport christophe caresche ne
veut pas toucher ni aux 35 heures n'est
au cdi du salaire minimum à quoi va-t-il
servir si c'est pour ne toucher à rien
du tout si si d'abord c'est un projet
très important parce que le chômage
continue de progresser dans notre pays
on a fait un certain nombre de choses
mais on voit bien que il faut aller plus
loin et même aujourd'hui alors qu'on
n'est pas très loin de 2017 je pense que
le gouvernement a raison de vouloir
continuer à essayer de trouver des
solutions et à réformer
je partage ce qui est dit c'est à dire
il faut que ces réformes soient
suffisamment significative pour qu'elle
ait des effets est ce morceau
certificative je pense que la logique
qui est proposée notamment par robert
badinter qui est de dire et par le
gouvernement qui est de dire on va
renvoyer toute une série de choses à la
négociation soit dans les branches dans
les entreprises c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important c'est même une
petite révolution dans ce pays parce que
cela signifie que va se négocier au plus
près du besoin des andes et entreprises
toute une série de choses notamment
bon alors il ya débat est assez
technique mais notamment la question du
temps de travail on le touche pas à la
35 heures ne touche certes pas aux 35
heures mais on va toucher à la manière
dont les discuter les heurts qui sont
travaillés au delà des 35 heures mecs
que je ne sais qu'il ya des gens
aujourd'hui il ya des gens aujourd'hui
qu'ils travaillent plus de 35 heures
dans ce pays
est ce que vous auriez souhaité vous
qu'on touche aux 35 heures non je trouve
que c'est un débat très comment
dirais-je symbolique comme on les aime
dans ce pays c'est un tabou c'est ed oui
espèce de deux tabous c'est d'aimer mais
encore une fois j'ai quand on regarde la
réalité ce débat il n'a pas beaucoup de
sens
la suppression des 35 heures ça voudrait
dire quoi ça va ça voudrait dire qu'on
allonge le temps de travail sans payer
les heures
plémentaires ce que propose certaines
personnalités de la droite dans leur
programme bruit et notamment il ya un
rapport au sénat qui le propose
ce n'est pas ni ce que propose
évidemment le premier ministre ni ce que
propose d'ailleurs emmanuel macron il
n'a jamais proposé cela ce que l'on
propose c'est de dire qu'il peut y avoir
une marge de négociation sur la comble à
la valorisation du puisque au delà de 35
heures
vous avez un seuil minimum qui est de 25
% ou 10 % d'augmentation du salaire de
leurs supplémentaires nous ce qu'on
propose c'est que cette question soit
soumise à la négociation il me emmanuel
macron j'appelle a pas réussi à passer
là si si si vous aurez une et glacial ce
soir qu'on s'en va pas être trop
technique mais aurait alors faire et que
ce soit en dessous on va d'abord moi je
considère que ça ça se discute ça ça
fait partie de la discussion reste à
négocier sur la scène négocier ça fera
partie de la discussion au parlement
bon moi ça ne me choque pas qu'on aille
en dessous des 10%
qu'est ce que dit emmanuel macron c'est
exactement la même logique qu'il a eu
sur le travail du dimanche
le travail du dimanche on a dit c'est
aux partenaires sociaux de négocier les
compensations salariales
il y avait un certain nombre de députés
notamment benoît hamon je me suis très
bien
qui dit il faut fixer un seuil minimum
monsieur macron a dit non parce que il
faut d'abord faire confiance aux
partenaires sociaux et deuxièmement en
fixant un seuil minimum vous allez
mettre tout le monde au seuil bon ce qui
s'est passé et ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans la négociation c'est
qu'on constate que les syndicats
obtiennent énormément pas énormément ils
obtiennent des avancées très
significatives sur les salaires donc il
faut faire confiance aux syndicats et
moi je considère qu'il a pas nécessité
de fixer un seuil on va voir aussi sur
les autres textes que vous pensez et
notamment aussi sur les manifestations
en tout genre comme lieu mardi
une forte mobilisation dans la rue
notamment du secteur des fonctionnaires
mais il ya eu aussi les taxis qui ont
mobilisé toute la semaine
regardez ce reportage d'elsa monde un
gamin qui va vous expliquer un petit peu
tout ce qui s'est passé autour des taxis
et notamment des explications sur cette
loi thévenoud qui va être modifié sans
2014 une proposition de loi était
adoptée elle devait pacifier les
relations entre les taxis et les vtc
oui il ya de la place pour tout le monde
d'un côté modernisation des taxis avec
par exemple terminal de carte bancaires
obligatoires
d'autre part interdiction pour les bd
c'est de circuler sont réservés sur
préalable
mais selon l'auteur de la loi thomas
thévenoud celle ci n'est à ce jour pas
correctement appliqué pour un des
raisons de moyens parce que c'est vrai
qu'il faut déployer les forces de police
aujourd'hui la police des taxis ces 90
bauer on les appelle comme ça pour 20000
taxi et 7 millions et essayez donc
évidemment ils sont fort peu nombreux
plusieurs incidents se sont produits
donnant lieu à une vingtaine
d'arrestations
le premier ministre a condamné ces
violences manuel valls le ministre de
l'intérieur et celui des transports ont
ensuite reçu à matignon une délégation
de représentants d'organisations
professionnelles de taxi et les réunions
se sont succédé toute la semaine toute
la semaine a été marquée par cette grève
des taxis avec des violences aussi quand
même très forte trop gros vous condamnez
tout cela oui je condamne tout cela tu
veux dire une chose très très clair
c'est les taxis sont d'abord victimes
d'un système qui a été encouragée
d'ailleurs accepté en tous les cas par
l'état mais qui a été aussi accepté par
la profession elle-même qui a consisté à
créer à mettre sur le marché des
licences administrative a créé une
véritable bulle autour de ces licences
qui ont été multipliées par quatre
depuis les années 2000
et je comprends que les taxis et
notamment les derniers taxi qui sont
arrivés et qu'ils ont acheté ces
licences se préoccupent de leur avenir
ils ont raison
mais la question ce n'est pas d'empêcher
les autres de travailler c'est pas ça la
question
la question c'est de régler ce problème
alors et donc il faut maintenant
l'affronter ce problème c'est comment on
fait parce qu'évidemment cette bulle
elle va finir un jour ou l'autre par
explose là c'est le cas donc la question
elle est en train effectivement
d'exploser naturellement est bon il ya
des responsabilités
il ya au passage quand même des gens qui
sont seront mis pas mal dans la dent
dans la poche
parce que ces dix ans elles ont été
donnés gratuitement elles sont
aujourd'hui à plus de 2 elle est
sérieusement ceux qui ont acheté des
licences dans les années 2000 qui
étaient autour de kay de 40000 euros
elle coûtait à l'époque quarante ou
cinquante mille euros
elles ont été jusqu'à 200 milles euros
donc vous voyez la plus belle une
changement des choses depuis on a
l'impression qu'ils aient que c'est un
peu la cacophonie que ce secteur est un
peu livré à lui même est ce qu'il faut
que l'état est at il les moyens surtout
de reprendre un peu
moi je je pense que ce sac il ya ce
problème des taxis ça je pense qu'il
faut que l'état
je pense qu emmanuel macron a fait des
propositions intéressantes règle ce
qu'on essaye de trouver une sortie sur
cette question des licences mais il ya
mentalement c'est ça qui à mon avis
plombe le dossier il ya la situation des
vtc
alors je parle de la situation des vtc
je considère avec chauffeur impôts c'est
que là bas je considère d'abord que il y
a un potentiel de croissance dans ce
secteur très important
donc il ya de la place pour tout le
monde pour parler clairement et je crois
que l'état aurait tort de freiner le
développement des vtc et notamment je
demande à au gouvernement de prendre
l'arrêté sur les formations des
chauffeurs est toujours pas pris et qui
bloque aujourd'hui la formation de vos
coups de réformes etc si on est trop des
taxis aux dépens de langues
je force que il y a chez certains l'idée
est notamment aussi de l'opérateur qui
est quand même très en position
dominante mais chez les taxis
il ya une volonté de de faire porter la
rue d'une responsabilité qui est la leur
qui est d'abord la leur sur les autres
ça ce n'est pas acceptable qu'il faut
remettre de l'ordre dans tout ça est
appelé c'est ce que nous faisons c'est
vrai que la loi thévenoud disons le
clairement ça a été une ligne maginot
bon allez l'imaginons elles sont
contournées à ce que n'a pas servi à
grand chose pour vous elle a pas servi à
grand chose si elle a un peu amusés la
situation mais
donc là il y avait un certain nombre de
dispositions qui étaient qui sont pas
appliquées parce qu'elle était
inapplicable
j'y arrivais les amendements au dernier
moment j'étais dans l'émission moi j'ai
dénoncé ça quand j'ai vu arriver les
amendements où on demandait aux vtc de
retourner à la base etc
c'est des trucs qui sont évidemment on
apprécie de l'appliquer il faut une
nouvelle loi il faut la loi moi je suis
pas un fanatique de la législation à
tout prix c'est pas dans la loi qu on
règle tous les problèmes mais il faut
retrouver effectivement une une comment
dirais-je un cadre dans lequel qui
permettent à tout le monde de se
développer et il faut régler le problème
des taxis et le problème des taxis c'est
les licences séville s'est dit on va
poursuivre la semaine
une passe d'armes a eu lieu christophe
caresche à l'assemblée sur le projet de
construction de l'aéroport notre dame
des landes vous étiez dans l'hémicycle
cécile duflot s'est fait répondre
sèchement par manuel valls écouter le
président de la république françois
hollande a déclaré en direct à la radio
le 5 janvier 2015
tant que les recours ne sont pas et
cuisez le projet ne peut pas être lancé
à ce jour plus de dix sept recours sont
toujours en cours y compris au niveau
européen
il porte notamment sur la loi sur l'eau
et la biodiversité ma question est
simple
pouvez vous nous confirmer ici monsieur
le premier ministre que vous ne trahirai
pas la parole du président de la
république je le rappelle ce projet est
en effet soutenu par l'ensemble des
collectivités locales il s'agit de qui
madame duflot du président du conseil
départemental du président du conseil
régional qui chez la même position que
de son prédécesseur de la maire de
nantes de plusieurs parlementaires de
l'ancien premier ministre jean-marc
ayrault dont vous étiez vous-même
membres du gouvernement ont-ils tort
madame duflot
koné style moins bien que vous
la réalité du terrain on a l'impression
que cécile duflot manuel valls sont sur
des positions inconciliables vous avez
ressenti aussi vous ce dialogue de
sourds
oui mais je pense que manuel valls a
raison c'est un problème c'est un projet
local régional c'est pas un projet
national
moi je suis de ceux qui pensent que les
problèmes régionaux il faut qu'il soit
réglé au niveau régional et donc ou bien
vous ressentez quand même le combat
politique
oui bien sûr qu'il est bien sûr que
mathilde nation etc
mais je suis toujours frappé de voir que
dans ce pays tout remonte au niveau
central au niveau du premier ministre et
c'est quand on a un problème on demande
un rendez-vous au premier ministre
connaissait les connais je le dis
sincèrement parce qu'on est un pays sans
doute hyper centralisé mais ces
questions là elles doivent se régler
dans un cadre local ce n'est pas un
projet de national bon voila et et
manuel valls a raison de dire qu'il ya
un consensus politique le projet sur
l'eau pour le faire le projet se fera
malgré les nos pages région où il va
sans dire que le projet a été décidée
parce que le droit le permet donc
évidemment la laddh pour le dessin très
simple processus se met très simple et
très politique et sauvetage
est ce que vous pensez vous avez encore
besoin des écologistes gouvernement bah
moi je suis assez désespérée par
l'évolution des écologistes parce que je
pense que c'était comment dirais-je un
partenaire très important pour nous à la
fois sur le plan idéologique et sur le
plan politique et je suis vraiment
consterné de voir que ce parti qui
pouvait être un appui très important ce
soit se retrouve finalement dans une
situation de fracture de difficultés
pour se faire entendre et une partie
dure ce parcours une partie d'un
programme qui est en train de basculer
dans une surenchère
qui à mon avis n'est pas audible une
espèce de contestation permanente de
tous bref donc
donc voilà je pense que c'est dû moi
pour vous dire ce que je c'est un grand
gâchis
voilà aurait-il leur place aujourd'hui
une ancienne gouvernement certains bien
évidemment certains ont parfaitement
leur place dans le gouvernement il le
soutiennent je pense à françois de rugy
à barbara pompili ya tout et c'est
simple à celle ci était au petit théo
que eux et eux sont restés
je trouve assez fidèle à l'engagement
qui avait été pris en 2012
et malgré les difficultés essaye de les
affronter et d'avancer je suis beaucoup
plus sévères pour l'attitude de cécile
duflot pour rien vous cacher et pendant
ce temps là on parle d'écologie pour
l'instant est donc les sénateurs ont
voté à une très large majorité un texte
très important qui est celui sur la
biodiversité texte d'envergure depuis
1965 sur la protection de la nature il
devrait ensuite revenir à l'assemblée
nationale christophe caresche en
deuxième lecture avant une adoption
définitive afin d'en avant la fin de
l'année traite de façon très courte pour
une dira peut-être si ce texte est d'un
enjeu majeur et pourquoi ce qu'il est
aussi noms à coucher près de quatre ans
le texte sur sur la biodiversité
ça c'est un endettement massif des
parlementaires c'était très très long
serait médecin c'est la mairie de
l'urgence sur ce texte peut-être pas il
ya eu les gars calendrier parlementaire
bon voilà c'est pas la priorité enfin
tout le monde a l'air comme deux sont
félicités donc les tailles qui qui qui
qui sont longs à une discuter et qui
arrive un consensus s'est pas forcément
les mêmes thèmes aussi sur les
collectivités notamment sur ces
nouvelles régions de france y est le
nouveau président des régions de france
qui a été élu c'est philippe richert tu
sais le patron de la région alsace
champagne-ardennes lorraine
il a été choisi leur place alain rousset
ses patrons de région et sauf cas reste
c'est un peu les nouveaux barons ça ne
peut rien faire sans eux notamment sur
la question du chômage c'est le lien
entre le gouvernement le voit ou de lire
très fort qui unit le gouvernement et
ses présidents de région aujourd'hui moi
je
enfin je ne vois pas comme des points de
blocage je vois au contraire comme des
appuis je pense qu'on doit aller vers la
régionalisation plus forte d'un certain
nombre de politiques alain rousset s'est
beaucoup débattu pour cela très
courageusement et d'ailleurs avec raison
moi je l ai soutenu à chaque fois que
je le pouvais c'est vrai que dans les
lois de décentralisation il ya encore
beaucoup de choses à faire mais par
exemple sur ce que dit monsieur bertrand
sur l'emploi sur le chômage
je suis tout à fait d'accord pour que
une partie de la politique
d'accompagnement des chômeurs de
l'emploi soit décentralisée au niveau
des régions il faut le faire parce qu'on
sait que c'est là qu'il y à plus
d'efficacité la nation pour répondre à
cela absolument est donc xavier bertrand
a fait des propositions quand je trouve
très positive jeudi au passage qu'un
amendement avait été votée à l'assemblée
nationale pour faire ce que demande
monsieur bertrand et que le gouvernement
s'y était in fine est opposé bon je le
regrette
c'est madame iborra qui avait proposé
cet amendement c'était un amendement
tout à fait pertinents j'espère qu'on va
reprendre ce travail
alors on va passer à la séquence
politique de la semaine mercredi
décision qui n'a pas vraiment surpris
mikea frappé tout le monde s'est tu as
mercredi désaccord politique majeur
c'est la raison invoquée par christiane
taubira pour justifier son départ du
gouvernement après près de quatre ans
passés au ministère de la justice celle
qui incarnait la caution de gauche de la
gauche de françois hollande a repris sa
liberté un départ très commentée germain
andrieu c'est une demi surprise et
surtout une requête incessantes des
républicains qui réclamait sa démission
après ses déclarations contre la
déchéance de nationalité
le statu quo sur la garde des sceaux
était devenue intenable pour
l'opposition la situation dans laquelle
se trouvait madame taubira était
totalement ahurissante exprimé une
opposition forte réitéré à un texte
porté par le gouvernement et se
maintenir dans le gouvernement était
totalement inédit vous avez au moins 2
ans qui est plus de y'a plus de garde
des sceaux donc de ce point de vue là ça
changera sans doute pas grand chose
simplement ce que ça acte aujourd'hui
c'est clairement une fissure qui
s'agrandit au sein de au sein de la
majorité
une démission avec un calendrier très
précis c'est aujourd'hui que s'ouvre le
débat sur la révision constitutionnelle
de la déchéance de nationalité
tout avait déjà été tranchée c'est
manuel valls qui soutiendra le temps
dans l'hémicycle les scénes taubira
avait des désaccords de plus en plus
grand avec certaines politiques du
gouvernement je crois que la
problématique de la déchéance de
nationalité a conduit à cette démission
donc à partir de là elle a tiré les
conséquences sûrement de ces désaccords
politiques
avec l'orientation actuelle du
gouvernement sur une affaire comme ça un
moment donné ben ça explose elle ne peut
pas continuer à être complice d'une
politique qu'elle n'approuve pas une
démission la garde des sceaux acceptée
par françois hollande pour la remplacer
jean jacques urvoas a été nommé ce
député proche de manuel valls présidait
la commission des lois
depuis 2012 est-ce que vous avez été
surpris par ce départ est ce que c'est
au contraire la conclusion politique
logique
oui je pense que - conclusion tout à
fait logique je pense que ça aurait été
très compliqué pour madame taubira
alors que sont le texte qu'elle aurait
dû porter était en discussion de ne pas
ne pas le présenter ne pas le soutenir
au parlement je pense qu'il ya un moment
effectivement ou le désaccord devient
devient ingérable donc voilà elle en a
tiré les conclusions et c'est assez
logique l'impression que le chemin ça y
est la route est dégagée ya plus de
contestataires au gouvernement c'est
parti parce qu'il ya deux logiques si
vous voulez il ya une logique
d'efficacité qui passe par la cohérence
qui passe par la cohésion du
gouvernement encore autant de manuel
valls
mais je pense qu'il a raison je
comprends qu'en tant que premier
ministre il soit attaché à cela et puis
il y à une logique de rassemblement et
il ya un moment où ces deux logiques
sont incompatibles surtout quand les
difficultés sont là et qu'elles sont
très importantes
donc effectivement je comprends
qu'aujourd'hui le chef du gouvernement
il présentera les publics privilégient
plutôt une logique d'efficacité et de
cohérence
je le regrette parce que je pense que
sur le rassemblement d'autre aurait
évidemment vocation à être au
gouvernement
mais si c'est pour simplement afficher
ces différences afficher ses désaccords
ça n'a aucun intérêt que vous êtes en
train de vous dire que seuls qui ne
peuvent être au gouvernement que ceux
qui sont d'accord avec la ligne de but
je pense qu'aujourd'hui je pense
qu'aujourd'hui cette question elle est
en partie les du président de la
république vienne et de là dire que
c'est la logique de cohérence
d'efficacité qui prévaut qui doit
prévaloir
et je pense que ce choix il est assez
juste par rapport aux difficultés qui
sont devant nous parce que l'année 2016
va être difficile il va y avoir
probablement là aussi des imprévus et
c'est bon donc cette logique là et
évidemment c'est un pari c'est toujours
un appareil de son la politique c'est le
pari que in fine et les français
reconnaîtront cela reconnaîtront la
cohérence se reconnaîtront la fidélité
dans l'action ça mais également ce qui
fait dire aussi que ces mêmes
contestataires dont vous parliez se sont
peut-être trouvé aussi une nouvelle chef
de file de leur contestation ou craignez
ça c'est cela un je ne sais pas ce
qu'elle veut faire elle ce que je vais
prendre un temps de l ai pas dit des
choses de manière assez prudente par
rapport à cela moi j'ai beaucoup
d'estimé pour pour elle c'est vraiment
une femme qui a eu qui a porté
d'ailleurs par eux par sa réflexion par
son frère ben pas par par beaucoup de
choses par sa sensibilité
mais je ne sais pas ce qu'elle voudra
faire ce qui est vrai c'est qu'il y a
mais j'allais dire c'est presque devenu
une comment dirais-je une variante
constat il ya une gauche qui s'est
positionné dans la comtesse environ 110
lé plus dangereux à l'extérieur ou
l'intérieur
je n'en sais rien je ne pose pas la
question comme ça tu en as un sac qui en
a un certain nombre qui souhaitent
l'instrumentaliser dans leur combat
contre le gouvernement
ça m'a pas échappé et ça n'a pas échappé
aux observateurs
maintenant ça dépendra de ce qu'elle
veut faire elle le bidon de christiane
taubira par le voyage pour tous c'est
quoi moi je pense qu'elle a un bilan
positif
dans un contexte où la justice aussi des
défis tout à fait immenses à relever
voilà c'est plus c'est pas simple pour
la justice parce que c'est une
institution comme beaucoup
d'institutions qui et qui est confronté
à des chocs très importants et notamment
un choc qui est la massification des
contentieux donc c'est une institution
qui qui qui vit des difficultés je
trouve qu'elle a plutôt bien géré cela
elle agirait quelque chose de manière
très positive
c'est l'indépendance de la justice
écoutez ce que disait manuel valls à
propos du départ de christiane lambert
la gauche au pouvoir est confronté au
réel et parce qu'elle gouverne dans une
période particulièrement difficile
elle doit tenir il ya toujours la
tentation de partir il ya toujours la
tentation de fuir ses responsabilités
quand c'est difficile
elle doit résisté et résisté au cours
des choses pour tracer sa voie et
résister aujourd'hui ça n'est pas
proclamer ce n'est pas faire des
discours
résister c'est se confronter à la
réalité du pays se confronte à la
réalité du bail il a entièrement raison
il ya une gauche qui ne veut pas
gouverner qui ne veut pas assumer la
responsabilité parce qu'elles
considèrent que passer des compromis
c'est trahir voilà et ses tailleurs
aveuglant dans les propos que tiennent
un certain nombre de responsables qui
représentent cette gauche là elles
préfèrent se replier dans le confort qui
consiste à ne jamais comment dirais-je
c'est qu'il sait boucher
ce serait faux pas c'est celle qui
dénonce en permanence la trahison de
ceux qui gouvernent aujourd'hui c'est
celle qui se réfugient dans des postures
morales politiques mais qui ne ne
construit rien il ne construit rien
c'est une gauche destructrice ce n'est
pas une gauche qui construit quoi que ce
soit et honnêtement je leur souhaite
bien du courage parce que quand je vois
les uns et les autres
alors il s'invite entre eux les uns les
autres
bon pour faire quoi personne ne le sait
bon donc c'est une gauche qui est
purement dans la contestation dans la
protestation et qui fondamentalement ne
veut pas prendre
des responsabilités comme sa déchéance
de nationalité d'ailleurs dans un petit
peu plus sur le contenu du texte en
phase avec alix pichot le premier
ministre en personne est venu devant la
commission des lois
présenté le texte du projet de loi
constitutionnelle le coeur du sujet
l'article 2 qui porte sur l'extension de
la déchéance de nationalité pour les
terroristes à l'origine le gouvernement
voulait ainsi cette déchéance pour les
binationaux dans la constitution
face à l'opposition à gauche il a
finalement choisi une formule plus
prudente
le gouvernement a décidé en accord avec
le président de la république de
proposer une nouvelle rédaction
aucune référence à la binationalité le
figura dans le texte constitutionnel ni
a priori dans la loi ordinaire
le premier ministre a réaffirmé que la
révision constitutionnelle ne pourrait
créer d'apatrides ce qui implique que la
déchéance de nationalité ne
s'appliquerait bien qu binationaux même
ceux nés en france comme l'avait promis
le président face au congrès pour
maintenir un principe d'égalité les
autres français pourraient se voir
privés des droits attachés à la
nationalité
le principe d'égalité commandes aussi
bien sur le plan moral que juridique
d'unifier les régime applicable aux
personnes condamnées en courant la
déchéance qu'elle soit naturalisés ou
les françaises autre nouveauté le
premier ministre souhaite que la
déchéance ouvre aussi aux délits elle ne
serait donc plus limité aux seuls crimes
une concession faite à la droite qui
souhaite un élargissement du champ
d'application de la déchéance à ces
annonces l'opposition prise de court et
mais un premier avis plutôt prudent mais
semble rester ouverte au dialogue il
faut encore qu'on est la démonstration
que ce soit bien par une révision de la
constitution qu'on arrive au plus
d'efficacité
voilà où l'eau reste à ce stade tant
qu'on n'a pas d'autres éléments les
débats dans l'hémicycle débuteront le 5
février prochain
alors la référence à la binationalité ne
figurera donc plus noir sur blanc dans
le texte et pourtant certains à gauche
dit c'est un jeu d'écriture c'est une
hypocrisie ce matin pascal cherki parlé
de forfaiture politique vous la répondez
quoi
d'abord ce que vous trompiez
nous on veut parler de sa part en
particulier non je pense que c'est une
très bonne chose je trouve que la
l'écriture qui a été introduite la seule
chose que je regrette c'est qu'elle elle
a été introduite dès le début voilà
soyons clair ça aurait peut-être évité
les allez tout un certain nombre de wii
un certain nombre d'interrogations
parce que ce qui est ce qui est
évidemment les binationaux ne sont pas
concernés en tant que guides nationaux
il serait concerné s'il commettait des
actes de terrorisme brise vent c'est
terrorisant on sait donc que soyons
clairs ils commettent des délits graves
c'est ou des délits graves ou et bien
sûr crimes et avait à ce jour cette
affaire elle et elle et elle est très
symbolique au fond donc ce que fait le
gouvernement c'est qu'ils retirent le
symbole et c'est vrai que beaucoup ont
dit j'ai encore vu patrick weil on en a
discuté encore cette semaine la
fondation jean jaurès
beaucoup ont dit le problème c'est que
ce soit dans la constitution
c'est pas le fait qu'il y ait des
chances de nationalité d'ailleurs les
chances de traiter elle existe dans
notre droit de l'hésitation c'est que ce
soit dans notre constitution dans
d'autres pays donc je trouve que il a le
gouvernement à retirer au fond quelque
chose qui je pense doit apaiser le débat
et y intervenir avec ce soit dans la
constitution non pardon si c'était
symbolique nomination excusez moi je
parle des binationaux oui il fallait que
la déchéance de nationalité soit dans la
constitution d'ailleurs c'est ce que dit
l'avis du conseil d'état
moi je pense que sur ce point là le
gouvernement a eu raison de suivre
l'avis du conseil d'état
parce que ça les visent évidemment vous
voyez que le gouvernement fait des
compromis qu'ils arrivent à satisfaire
ma ne nous rassurent mais mais mais de
même que le président le premier
ministre à rechercher ce qui est bien
normal
l'adhésion à la fois de la gauche ou
d'une partie de la gauche pour ce cas
une partie de la gauche ce sont qui ne
votera pas voter le texte toujours une
pour les mêmes raisons ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure
donc les goûts dans une prestation de
principe si vous voulez bon donc ils ne
voteront pas mais je pense que beaucoup
et notamment j'ai vu qu'au sein du
groupe socialiste
un certain nombre de ceux qui avaient
des interrogations
se sont ralliés à cette donc vous pensez
qu'il y aura une majorité pour voter le
deuxième point c'est que le premier
ministre a aussi essayé de faire des
compromis de l'autre côté parce que il
faut trois cinquièmes
oui vous pensez vous voulez et 5 et 7
mois je
vous rappelle que la dernière révision
constitutionnelle de 2008 a été votée à
une voix une fois donc n'oubliez jamais
qu'une révision concessionnels rien et
c'est toujours excuser moi un exercice à
haut risque donc c'est compliqué les
présidents et politique
oui c'est dangereux mais parce que il en
a fait il en a fait le la condition du
rassemblement de l'unité nationale et
donc c'est la raison dans ce sens ce
moment là de faire dans un moment de
aussi comment dirais-je de d'un choc
aussi fort de vouloir essayer de
rassembler les français donc de
rassembler les forces politiques aussi
et je changeais bien peu union abbas est
clair que ceux qui voteront contre la
révision conscio neil voteront contre
l'unité nationale pour moi c'est très
clair
alors on va s'intéresser à au successeur
de christiane taubira olivia que vous
connaissez bien
jean jacques urvoas ses taux jeudi
jean-jacques urvoas et donc le nouveau
ministre de la justice il était jusqu
alors président de la commission des
lois voyons les dossiers qui seront sur
sa table avec stéphane et des pierres
premier chantier de jean jacques urvoas
la réforme constitutionnelle un objectif
dans la droite ligne de son travail à la
tête de la commission des lois à
l'assemblée nationale depuis quelques
semaines il était chargé par manuel
valls de trouver la formulation magique
pour inclure la déchéance de nationalité
dans la constitution
pour le reste le nouveau ministre de la
justice n'affiche pas des ambitions
démesurées
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire pendant
15 mois mon engagement se nouera sera de
ne pas chercher à bouleverser l'univers
judiciaire
mais à me concentrer sur la prise en
charge du présent seul gage d'un futur
maîtrisé pourtant christiane taubira
quitte la chancellerie on l'est sont de
gros dossiers sur la table la réforme de
la justice des mineurs
attendu depuis deux ans est sans cesse
repoussée ce texte voulant favoriser
l'éducatif et la prévention n'est
toujours pas à l'agenda parlementaire et
le nouveau garde des sceaux ne l'a pas
évoquée lors de la passation de pouvoir
autre projet cher à l'ancien ministre la
justice du 21e siècle
annoncé en 2014 et qui semble aussi au
point mort au grand projet jean jacques
urvoas
et faire les actions concrètes notre
justice est aujourd'hui en permanence au
bord de l'embolie et donc je vais
m'attacher pendant les quinze mois qui
viennent à faire en sorte que la seule
loi d'importance soit votée c'est à dire
la loi de finances enfin le nouveau
ministre de la justice devra faire
passer au parlement la réforme pénale
dont le volet sécuritaire inquiète une
partie du monde judiciaire
car elle vous présente jean jaras est
notre partenaire du scan qui va vous
intéresser quelques petites minutes
d'abord katia sur jean jacques urvoas
jean jacques urvoas à peine nommé qui a
imposé un peu sa marque est ce que c'est
l'homme qu'il fallait à ce poste j'en
vois c'est the right man at the right
place comme on dit en bon français
oui bien sûr admet l'acteur je ne
garantis pas c'est le bon bout non c'est
un très bon choix et et je pense qu'il a
à la fois l'expérience la compétence il
est extrêmement reconnu à au parlement
et je crois ce qu'il a dit est très
juste la justice encore une fois est
confrontée à une massification des
contentieux un choc extrêmement
importants comme l'éducation nationale
et d'un certain point de vue avec la
démocratisation de l'enseignement et
donc c'est vrai qu'il faut des moyens il
faut des moyens et il faut encore plus
de moyens et vous possédez la région de
dire que c'est la loi de finances qui
sait qu'il aura gain de cause
mettre des gens on a fait beaucoup
d'efforts et d'ailleurs je constate que
c'est des efforts qui ont été plutôt
continue dans compris avec les albums
dans les nerfs dernier y compris des
alternats ministères prioritaires
oui absolument il ya eu beaucoup de
continuer à faire un effort jean jacques
urvoas et quand même connu pour être
assez proche de la police en tout cas de
tout ce qui est du côté de l'intérieur
est ce que vous n'avez pas la crainte
que la police prédomine la justice
aujourd'hui
non d'abord
jean jacques est un professeur de droit
public
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas il ay là il a
travaillé sur les questions de sécurité
à la demande d'ailleurs de martine aubry
quand il était secrétaire national ces
questions mais il vient d'abord du droit
c'était un homme de droit de c'est un
juriste dans un livre dans un livre
dominante s'il voulait rassembler police
alors est-il celui que je connais très
bien et vous les supprimez la préfecture
de police ils voulaient oui ce livre
c'est c'était tout les propos toutes les
réformes qui ne seront pas fait a donc
voila c'était c'est à dire rien c'est
d'ailleurs un côté le préfet délivre
alors c'est un côté tout à fait oui mais
ça sert à réfléchir
c'est un côté sympathique et éminemment
intéressant chez jean jacques urvoas
c'est que c'est un homme qui a beaucoup
de liberté l'intellectuel est
effectivement il avait écrit un livre
assez amusant surtout s'il n'est pas
faire en politique c'est toutes les
réformes qui ne fallait pas faire et ils
ne se feront pas aimé qui permettait
effectivement de poser un certain nombre
de débats qui sont des vrais débats
on voit ça va lui faire plaisir voit
passer tout de suite à notre rubrique
avec jim jarrassé gym c'est à vous on
commence par une phrase qui était
prononcée cette semaine par aurélie
filippetti on le sait qui et opposante à
la question de la déchéance de
nationalité
le gouvernement de françois hollande at
elle dit prend un virage autoritaire
comment en est on arrivé à cette
situation une députée socialiste qui
plus est ancien ministre accuse
l'exécutif d'une quasi dérive
dictatoriale
oui c'est une plaisanterie qui peut
prendre qui peut croire ça qui peut
prendre ça au sérieux
vous êtes ces déclarations qui sont
tellement excessive qu'elle devienne
effectivement insignifiante
personne ne peut croire que la france
est en train de
d'entrée dans une ambiance dans un
régime policier ou autoritaire ce n'est
pas sérieux télé but de sept chercheurs
puisque vous la décrivez ainsi je pense
qu'il ya peut-être du ressentiment
personnel chez certains qui ont été
ministres qu'ils sont plus c'est
toujours difficile évidemment
enfin bon hôtel à cannes aurélie
filippetti et les autres la gauche
destructrice dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure par la travers ses déclarations
oui parce que je pense que faire croire
aux français que nous allons vers un
régime dictatorial si vous voulez c'est
pas c'est pas sérieux il faut moi ce qui
me frappe c'est que dans dans la dans le
débat public aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup
de responsables politiques qui
s'expriment de manière irresponsable
il faut il faut il faut garder quand
même la rigueur au moins un intellectuel
ils ont été plusieurs à prendre position
justement profitant du départ de
christiane taubira on est entendu benoît
hamon d'anthony delphine batho on a
entendu
arnaud montebourg qui a qui a fait un
tweet pour féliciter un christiane
taubira de son départ est-ce que
l'exécutif doit craindre la constitution
d'une sorte de ligue d'anciens ministres
entrer en résistance contre mais je
compte aller je comprends qu'il y ait
des déclarations sur christiane taubira
de sympathie de proximité et ça moi je
n'ai pas du tout de problème avec ça
aidons dans ceux que vous avez cités il
ya sans doute cette cette dimension par
contre c'est vrai que certains et depuis
maintenant des mois sont entrés dans une
logique dans une stratégie qui est une
stratégie alternative à ce que l'on fait
ce que fait le parti socialiste c'est
donc la question est de savoir jusqu'où
ils vont aller où cela va-t-il les mener
mais moi je n'en sais rien ça n'aura pas
de rien ça leur appartient cette
question leur appartient ils faut qu'ils
y répondent
mais le risque c'est je crois un joli
stationné jeudi que ces destructeurs
parce que je ne crois pas c'est une
alternative je n'en crois d'autant je
n'y crois d'autant moins que les
français n'ont pas l'air d'être apte
très attiré par les
les quand ils votent par les thèses qui
sont défendues par ces responsables
politiques
la natation autres de gauche pour 2017
oui peut-être je ne l'exclus pas mais il
ya un moment où il faut aussi que les
choses soient posées et une fille née
c'est quand même les français des
électeurs qui tranche est question là
ceci dit en 2017 faudra quand même être
un peu prudent parce qu' une telle
confrontation affaiblir et
inévitablement probablement le celui qui
pourrait représenter la gauche au
deuxième tour
donc il y aura là des responsabilités
très lourdes à prendre il ya un autre
type de deux frondeurs qui joue un peu
sa petite musique personnelle il s'agit
d'anne hidalgo vous qui êtes élu
parisien vous la connaissez bien elle
s'est à nouveau opposée à le week-end
dernier à la volonté d' emmanuel macron
de remettre en cause les 35 heures c'est
la nouvelle martine aubry
non je vais pas d'eux j'ai pas de de
critiques à franck lui fait vis-à-vis de
cette finale go ou 2 non mais je je je
vois là je la respecte elle est maire de
paris elle fait un bon travail à paris
pour le reste je pense qu'il faut encore
une fois que dans la période où nous
sommes et en particulier à gauche nous
avons une responsabilité particulière
nous sommes au pouvoir nous sommes en
responsabilité
il faut veiller à ce que les propos
soient respectueux des uns et des autres
face à la fronde l'ale droite du ps dont
vous faites partie se structurer veut
faire entendre sa voix on l'a bien
compris le pôle des réformateurs dont
vous faites parti qui s'est constitué
autour de soutien de manuel valls s'est
dotée début janvier d'une association de
financement
donc ça sert à collecter des dons oui
quoi ça sert une fille ça sert à
financer les maigres activités que nous
avons devons organiser par exemple une
journée d'été avec emmanuel macron
d'ailleurs à sac léognan chez mon ami
gilles savary et ça suppose quelques
petits moyens des petits moyens je
j'insiste là dessus et vous savez
peut-être nous ne savons pas que les
micro partis permettent de collecter
il s'agit en aucun cas préparer une
éventuelle candidate dans leur présence
les 10 de personnes de manuel valls en
particulier dans l'actualité du jour
c'est françois hollande main qui reçoit
aujourd'hui la famille de jacqueline
sauvage cette mère de famille qui en
prison après avoir tué son mari qui la
battait
et abusé également de ses enfants de
nombreux andres responsable politique à
gauche comme à droite ont pris position
en faveur de jacqueline sauvage et
réclament notamment une grâce
présidentielle est ce que vous êtes
favorable je suis très réservé sur cette
question parce que il y a eu deux
jugement en cour d'assises
je vous rappelle que la gauche parce que
c'est nous qui l'avons mis dans la loi
mais après que la droite les engager a
décidé de créer un appel en cour
d'assises et à partir de là je considère
que c'est très compliqué de de remettre
en cause un jugement lors de l'équipe
c'est pas le rôle des politiques
la grâce présidentielle au passage c'est
quand même un héritage de la monarchie
s'est passé c'est pas quelque chose de
très très républicain mais surtout dès
lors qu'il y à cet appel qu'il y a eu
deux de jugement c'est quand même
compliqué je vais vous dire ce que je
pense fondamentalement c'est que je
pense que cette personne a été très mal
défendu
parce que ses avocates ont voulu ce qui
est une erreur
les avocats le savent ont voulu défendre
une cause ou plutôt qu'une personne donc
si on vous entend bien pas vraiment pour
la grâce présidentielle et vous
souhaiteriez que france c'est d'abord ça
appartient au président de la république
en propre mais moi je suis réservé je
pense que pour parler clairement dans
ces situations là la grâce
présidentielle devrait même être
supprimés et ben voilà ce sera le mot de
la fin de cette émission merci beaucoup
christophe cage avoir été l'invité de
parlement hebdo très bonne semaine à
tous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour parlement hebdo